nos encontramos en el centro histórico
de Odessa que semanas atrás fue
designado por la UNESCO como monumento
histórico de la humanidad en una
iniciativa para salvarlo en un eventual
ataque de las fuerzas rusas que hace un
año Estuvieron muy cerca y esto era una
zona totalmente controlada y vigilada
por el ejército ucraniano hoy ha vuelto
a la una normalidad relativa sin embargo
lo que vemos es prácticamente las calles
todas oscuras unas pocas luces vienen de
ese teatro de la ópera uno de los
monumentos más importantes no solamente
de odesas sino de toda Ucrania y esto se
debe a que Odessa ha sido una de las
grandes ciudades de Ucrania sino la más
afectada por esos ataques a la
infraestructura energética por semanas
desde noviembre tuvieron grandes cortes
de Electricidad vivían a oscuras sin
calefacción y con falta de agua lo que
hizo que muchas personas se plantearan
de la ciudad especialmente quienes
trabajan también en una manera virtual
como mucha de la juventud que vive en
esta ciudad y en los últimos días cuando
ha vuelto a restablecerse la energía
muchas de las ciudades de Ucrania como
anunciaban las autoridades en el día de
hoy a quién odece el 25% de la ciudad al
menos Sigue con grandes cortes de
energía como podemos ver en este centro
histórico donde realmente sobreviven los
pequeños locales con plantas eléctricas